N
MISHANDLING FIREARMS AND NO IDEA
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND PROBABLY
NOT SURPRISING BUT INTERESTED
THAT HE'S AN ACTOR, OWNER OF
SPARTAGRIP.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THE REST OF US WOULD ASSUME THAT
A LOT OF ACTOR WHO IS WERE
AGAINST THE SECOND AMENDMENT
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT
GUNS.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING YOU HAVE SEEN
ACTORS MISHANDLE FIREARMS?
>> YEAH, THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON
FIRST OF ALL, TUCKER.
I APPRECIATE IT.
YEAH, IN MY INDUSTRY, WE DEAL
WITH A LOT OF FIREARM SCENARIOS
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF HOLLYWOOD
PEOPLE THAT WILL VILIFY FIREARMS
AND THEN END UP ON THEIR TV
SHOWS AND MOVIES AND GLORIFY
THEM IN THOSE INSTANCES AND IT'S
JUST THE HYPOCRISY OF IT AND I
KIND OF TRY TO BE PROFESSIONAL
ONSET BUT YOU RUN INTO THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE YOU'VE WATCHED
SOMEBODY MAKE STATEMENTS ON
THEIR TV SHOW OR THEIR
INTERVIEWS AND THEN YOU SEE THEM
ON THE SETS WORKING AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO BE USING THE FIREARMS.
IT'S JUST COMICAL.
>> Tucker: WELL, IT'S A LITTLE
WEIRD THAT PEOPLE WHO THINK GUNS
ARE EVIL WOULD BE AS YOU SAID
GLORIFYING THEIR USE PLAYING THE
TOUGH GUY, YOU KNOW, POINTING
GUNS IN PEOPLE'S FACES ON THE
SET.
HAVE YOU SEEN AN ACTOR DECLINE A
ROLE BECAUSE IT INVOLVED GUNS?
>> I'M SURE THE PAYCHECKS FAR
OUTWEIGH THEIR FEELINGS TOWARDS
FIREARMS.
>> Tucker: SO I GUESS IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING THAT A LOT OF
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT FIREARMS.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
YOU SEE THEM HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE NEWS
CHANNELS AND WITH POLITICIANS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE ABOUT
FIREARMS AND HEAR THINGS.
I GREW UP AROUND GUNS AND GREW
UP IN MONTANA AND AVID
OUTDOORSMAN AND HUNTING MY
ENTIRE LIFE AND YOU HEAR THEM
TALK ABOUT FIREARMS AND THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND EVEN THE
MECHANICS OF THEM TO BEGIN WITH
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE THEIR
POINT ACROSS OF WHY THEY'RE SO
BAD AND EVIL AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
YOU KNOW, HONEST HARD WORKING,
YOU KNOW, CITIZENS THAT LOVE
GUNS AND, YOU KNOW, MY GUN HAVES
NEVER HARMED ANYBODY OR NEVER
BEEN IN THE HANDS OF ANYBODY
THAT WOULD DO HARM.
YOU LOOK AT SCENARIOS AND KEEP
QUIET ON THE MOVIE SETS AND WORK
WITH THE INDIVIDUALS.
>> Tucker: NOT JUST YOU BUT
I'VE BEEN ON LOTS OF DIFFERENT
SETS AND THERE'S A HUGE DIVIDE
BETWEEN PEOPLE GETTING PAID THE
MOST AND ON CAMERA AND THEN
EVERYBODY, THE ARMY OF PEOPLE
OFF CAMERA THAT YOU NEVER SEE, I
WOULD SAY THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
DON'T SHARE THE POLITICS OF
PEOPLE ON CAMERA.
HAS THAT BEEN YOUR EXPERIENCE.
>> IN MY INDUSTRY, THERE'S THE
CONVERSATIONS BEHIND THE CAMERA
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
PROBABLY FEEL VERY SIMILAR TO
THE WAY THAT I FEEL WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE ISSUES.
YOU KNOW, BUT OF COURSE WE'RE
NOT MAKING THE $10 MILLION
PAYCHECKS SO WE'RE JUST THERE TO
DO OUR JOB AND DO IT TO THE BEST
OF OUR ABILI